las ciudades estratégicas del donbass se
enfrentan al avance de las fuerzas rusas
desde su giro táctico de finales de
marzo rusia afirma que quiere
concentrarse en la región del este de
ucrania pero ya no es su único objetivo
según las palabras de un alto
funcionario ruso el viernes desde el
inicio de la segunda fase de la
operación especial fácil que comenzó
hace dos días uno de los objetivos del
ejército ruso es establecer el control
total sobre el donbass y el sur de
ucrania
el general mímica jeff fue más allá el
control del sur de ucrania es también un
corredor hacia transnistria donde
también hay casos de opresión de la
población en rusoparlante transnistria
es un territorio moldavo fronterizo con
ucrania controlado desde 1992 por los
separatistas pro rusos y al igual que
hizo en el donbass rusia quiere
justificar una acción militar con el
pretexto de la opresión a la minoría
rusoparlante que reside allí en
respuesta moldavia convocó al embajador
ruso para expresarle su preocupación
estas declaraciones son infundadas y se
contradicen con el apoyo de rusia a la
soberanía y la integridad de nuestro
país en este pueblo cercano a la
frontera de transnistria los residentes
están preocupados por el avance de las
fuerzas rusas hacia el sur
por supuesto tenemos miedo de que la
guerra nos alcance también muchos dicen
que el enemigo no vendrá aquí pero quién
sabe qué pasará el voto otros que est al
menos 1.500 soldados rusos están en
transnistria desde
su misión oficial es el mantenimiento de
la paz